[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
martine filleul sénatrice socialiste du
nord bonsoir martine filleul merci
d'être avec nous lavaud côté fin de vie
en bon soir florian philippot président
des patriotes bonsoir florian philippot
merci d'être avec nous on va s'arrêter
quelques instants donc sur ces premières
annonces puisque cette conférence a
toujours lieu au moment où nous parlons
l'une des plus fortes le chef de l'état
qui annonce un référendum pour inscrire
la lutte contre le climat dans la
constitution c'est est ce que vous
attendiez notamment martine filleul et
écoutez moi je pense que le référendum
c'est une arme assez spectaculaire pour
emmanuel macron ça va lui permettre
d'asseoir en quelque sorte une
légitimité environnementale qu'il
n'avait pas réussi à avoir jusqu'à
présent puisqu'il a fait des
déclarations tout à fait contradictoires
donc ça doit lui permettre en tout cas
je l'espère d'associer les français
véritablement à la transition écologique
filippo c'est une annonce forte selon
vous ce référendum qu'est-ce que ça va
changer finalement concrètement est-ce
que ça a vraiment une portée aussi
importante qu'on le présente selon vous
le référendum tel qu'il est annoncé ne
changera rien
c'est à dire qu'il ajouterait un mot
l'article premier de la constitution
et quand je vois la masse de choses de
mesures très importantes pour la vie du
pays la vie de compatriotes que son
gouvernement a fait passer comme ça un
peu à la sauvette sans jamais consulter
le peuple français on se dit quand même
que c'est ça tout du marketing si vous
voulez il se fait un référendum pour
essayer essayer d'obtenir un bon
résultat électoral victoire électorale
sans trop de difficultés sur quelque
chose qui sera le sommes tous très
consensuel et comment être contre
l'ajout d'un terme aussi consensuel dans
la constitution mais ça ne réglera rien
on n'aimerait investir les sommes pour
savoir si on continue avec le modèle de
libre échange où est ce qu'on va vers
les circuits courts et protectionnisme
ça ce serait intéressant et ça c'est un
impact
sur notre vie vraiment ou bien un
référendum sur le fric site sur est ce
qu'on continue avec cette union
européenne qui a des politiques
d'ailleurs très polluantes ou est ce que
on retrouve une indépendance nationale
pour faire autre chose ça ce serait
respecté les français que de leur poser
cette question elle respecter leur
décision
préférez le choix du du référendum
marketing martine filleul vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec ce diagnostic de
référendum marketing comme nous dit
florian philippot est un peu sévère
selon vous c'est en tout cas de la part
d' emmanuel macron une manière de sortir
du piège dans lequel il s'était placé
avec cette convention citoyenne qu'il
avait créée en il avait en même temps
créé beaucoup d'espoir et il crée de la
déception par un certain nombre de
mesures qui ne vont pas jusqu'au bout et
avec ce référendum est bien une sorte de
ce piège est effectivement en faisant
valider en quelque sorte par les
français ces choix et donc en cela je
trouve que c'est extrêmement habile de
sa part
enfin mais ce n'est qu'une habile oui
tout à fait parce qu en quoi martine
filleul ça nous promet finalement des
actions concrètes et voilà c'est ça peut
se contenter d'être une déclaration
d'intention tout simplement voilà c'est
inscrit dans la constitution ça y est
j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait mais enfin
howell concret dans tout ça est ce que
ça nous le garantis florian philippot
ben non bien sûr que non mais vous savez
pendant que nous serons peut-être en
campagne d'afir under je ne sais pas si
ce sera très passionnant pour les
français sur ce mot dans la discussion
l'union européenne s'ils n'y aura de
nouveaux accords de libre échange elle
veut enseigner un nouveau là c'est
l'accord mercosur on a eu des nouvelles
macro avait annoncé qu'il avait bloqué
cet accord de libre échange avec les
pays d'amérique du sud dont le brésil
est bien une coalition de pays européens
plus de la commission européenne plus
l'ambassadeur de l'ue en peine au brésil
se sont réveillés pour forcer quand même
ce traité et ça c'est très polluants
parce que s'il voulait ça met des gros
cargo sur les océans
ça fait importer des sceaux gère
notamment dont on sait que c'est une des
causes
fall de déforestation de l'amazonie de
ça et ça ça va oui ça ça avance comme en
mars dernier l'union peine est soumis à
un accord de libre échange avec le
vietnam en avril avec le mexique etc
et voilà ça c'est concret et ça c'est
polluant et en plus ça détruit notre
agriculture est partie de notre
industrie etc
donc voila moi je regrette que la france
en soir en soit réduite comme ça avoir
un président qui fait qui fait un petit
coup politicien c'est effectivement une
habilité politicienne mais c'est avec
une habileté politicienne et
électoraliste
est ce ça devrait être jugé comme sa
part des français en tout cas les gars
ont la convention citoyenne avant cette
réunion qui est toujours en cours je le
rappelle puisque les décisions nous
arrive une par une
je suis d'accord sur le chèque
alimentaires notamment nous dit emmanuel
macron il faut qu'on le fasse et donc on
va le faire
en revanche report de la décision sur la
rénovation obligatoire des langes mans
un monde un manque d'ambition nous on
vit notamment le garant de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat serre ils
diront écouter discrètement le
gouvernement est en train de détricoter
et d'affaiblir bon nombre de leurs
mesures avant de les soumettre votre
formelle des députés ou des français
sinon tous pour qu emmanuel macron
respecte sa parole et soumettent sans
filtre les propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat ont référendum
et au parlement donc voilà de quoi
satisfaire cyril dion fin juin à
l'elysée en tout cas il s'était engagé à
reprendre son filtre 146 décomposition
initiale de de la convention je vous
propose d'écouter la réaction de
l'eurodéputée écologiste yannick jadot
cette fois ci ce quinquennat est perdue
pour le climat vous êtes d'accord
florian philippot les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les écoutent ce
quinquennat est tout simplement perdu
pour le climat oui je suis pas certain
qu'ils avaient caniggia dos avait changé
grand chose mais c'est pas bien pas
tenir sa parole ça c'est ça quand il
l'avait annoncé fin juin qui leur
prendrait toutes les mesures sauf 3 on
savait que ce serait fou je veux dire
pourquoi on savait que ce serait faux
faut se reporter un article du traité
publié dans marianne
juillet j'invite tout le monde il
exposera en ligne allez le voir il ya
énormément des propositions parfois très
intelligente qui ont été faits par cette
convention qui sont parfaitement
interdite aujourd'hui par le droit
européen van la modulation la tva des
taux de tva différents selon la distance
de votre nous via votre produit
c'est interdit par une directive
européenne qui date de 2006 et qui règle
la tva donc ça m'a qu'on aurait dû
savoir aurait dû informer les
conventionnels comme on dit les citoyens
il ressort que de toute façon il ne
pourrait pas le respecter
même chose sur renforcer les clauses
environnementales dans les marchés
publics etc
tout ça est codifié complètement au
niveau européen il y en a plein d'autres
un salaire minimum pour les petits
pêcheurs les petits éleveurs c'est une
belle idée on inscrivant sa dans la pac
mais ça n'est pas possible par la pâques
etc
il ya eu un mensonge et le départ ça a
été ça a été le non dit et non seulement
il ya des sujets qui étaient interdits
mais avant qu'il était interdit
d'aborder dans cette convention je sais
puisque chez moi j'ai eu moi même des
citoyens au téléphone m'ont contacté ils
m'ont dit dès qu'on allait sur le sujet
du libre-échange talent pour nous
recadrer tout de suite en disant ce
n'est pas le sujet ah si c'est sûr et
c'est un des grands sujets quand on
parle de d'environnement mais ça ils
n'avaient pas droit d'en parler
et deuxièmement il y avait plein de
propositions afin qu'ils ont fait à la
fin qui sont très bonnes mais qui sont
totalement impossible tant qu'on est
dans l'union européenne alors eu notre
colère est en train de monter c'est
celle-là représentant représentation
nationale députés et sénateurs demandent
un débat au parlement sur l'ensemble des
propositions
vous faites partie martin vial de ses
élus vous avez précisément signé cette
tribune qui elle va s'afficher sur nos
écrans la voici en titre vous
interpellez emmanuel macron respecter
vos engagements
c'est ce que vous dites au chef de
l'état martine filleul
expliquez-nous oui abst absolument je
fais partie de ces parlementaires qui
demande au chef de l'état d'avoir un
débat avec la représentation nationale
sur l'ensemble des propositions de la
convention citoyenne car encore une fois
il a suscité beaucoup d'espoir il a créé
cette convention est donc il faut qu'il
aille jusqu'au bout de la démarche
jusqu'au bout dans la transparence
jusqu'au bout dans la discussion et
encore une fois le président de la
république s'est mis dans un piège et
donc maintenant il faut qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout et qu'il accepte cette
discussion
la convention a fait des propositions
tout à fait concrète et je pense qu'on
peut les mettre en place
on peut les mettre à la disposition des
français
et moi je suis prête comme sénatrice a
travaillé sur chacune de ces
propositions en lien avec les citoyens
florian philippot finalement pourquoi
elles sont aussi compliqué de mettre en
oeuvre toutes ces propositions il y
avoir un principe de réalisme qui se
pose pour le chef de l'état est
finalement ce ne serait simple pour
personne quel que soit le parti
bon d'abord il ya il ya son idéologie
profs qui fait que sur certains sujets
il n'est pas accessible à une autre
vision des choses et ça je pense que
c'est fondamentalement macro est un
ultra libéral mondialiste et quand on
lui parle de éventuellement de
protectionnisme ou de régulation plus
forte dans un sens plus environnementale
et plus sociale ça va souvent ensemble
il entend pas parce que pour lui c'est
la loi du marché la loi du plus fort et
deuxièmement il ya ce que je vous disais
de toute façon il ya énormément de ces
propositions qui ne sont pas possibles
avec le droit européen parce que nous
sommes membres de l'union européenne
il faut avoir l'honnêteté de le dire
donc si on est conséquent sur ces sujets
là où quitte l'union européenne je crois
pas que ce soit le projet d' emmanuel
macron je le regrette amèrement et c'est
là dessus que j'aurais aimé un
référendum ça ça ça je sais que ça
passionnel pays martin fia la fota à
l'idéologie des manuels micron et ce
sera le mot de la fin pour vous une
question de courage politique et une
question d'ambition aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'héritage de la coop 21 au moment où 27
pays d
sid de relever l'objectif de la
réduction de gaz à effet de serre de 40
à 55 %
on se dit que décidément il n'est pas il
n'est pas à la hauteur pour la france
puisque ce n'est pas une question
européenne que de reprendre
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes par
exemple ou du cliff hosatte c'était bien
une question française en l'occurrence
merci en tout cas ce que filippo florian
philippot le mot de la fin
oui non mais justement sur le moi
j'avais dit dès le départ sur le vif aux
autres que max ne le ferai pas je
l'avais dit il ya trois ans parce que
justement il y aurait cette pression
européenne et énormément de choses qui
sont gérés au niveau européen y compris
sur les ibériques néonicotinoïdes et sur
les sur les pesticides etc
donc non là aussi vous savez on est
pieds et poings liés
il persiste et signe il a dix villes
heureux qu'ils le feraient rebond le
glyphosate on verra ce qu'il veut c'est
la lire vous donne raison merci en tout
cas martine filleul florian philippot
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france